[Music]
So today we are going to talk about data
as your differentiator or maybe about
coconuts. Let's see. Right. So that's
why I was like I'm confident that I'll
wake you up a little bit. And by the
way, these coconuts dance also
courtesy of Amazon Nova models. Okay,
enough about coconuts and um we'll
connect the dots and revisit our
coconuts because they're dancing and I
love dancing coconuts, right? Remind us
of the beach and the you know vacation
and everything. But let's come back from
vacation now. Serious work to do. Okay,
so we have been talking about generative
AI and um we all know that generative AI
adds lot of business value if done right
right that's a that's a big if and um it
can take your business to the highest
level as you can see in this image right
but however when you are building
something that big that can change how
your users interact with your
applications s then think about the
foundation right the foundation has to
be even deeper and what is that
foundation that's your data because your
data is representing your company your
brand your organization
so you have to get the data together and
we all know this since the very
beginning of machine learning world and
you would say money what is new that you
are that you are that you are you know
presenting over here. So the new thing
is that the data requirements for
building generative AI applications are
different. Generative AI is different
and so there are special treatment that
you need to give to the data based on
your uh application and the business
requirements. So that is exactly what we
are going to talk about today. And data
is not just about okay I have to
transform my data I have to load my data
I have to parse it I have to load it you
know all that stuff that is still there
and very important but the most
important thing is how is your data
interacting with the technology how is
it interacting with your people are do
you still have data silos if yes then
what about your applications because
these models can take up lots and lots
of data right so how are we doing with
all those interactions because no longer
we can afford to be in a silo and that's
what that's the exact reason why we have
to get our right and our foundation is
data. So let's see now there are certain
common applications let's take an
example and there are so many uh
applications the possibilities are
infinite right however let's you know
break it down and see with these three
applications how your uh data
requirements may differ the first
example is the travel agent so if you're
building a travel agent what kind of
data would you need first with that
travel agent it's going to interact with
your end users so It needs to know about
your customer profile, right? Because if
it doesn't know about your customer
profile, it's literally like um
remembering somebody's name when they
have left the room. How weird that would
be, right? Because you want to give
personalized experience and personalized
experience require personalized data and
it also brings up lot of responsibility
because you can no longer afford to have
PII information disclosed. You have to
be responsible. You have to maintain
your brand image. In addition to that,
you also need company data. For example,
your travel policies. If somebody asks
for a refund, whether that person
qualifies for the refund of the ticket
or not, it will be defined by your
travel policies, which airline, so on
and so forth, right? So, a lot goes into
when you are building like a virtual
agent, for example, a travel agent in
that scenario. However, if you're
building a conversational uh contextual
chatbot for improving the employee
productivity for common questions, what
do you really need? You need data about
your company. Absolutely. You need to
make sure that that employee has access
to that data and you are not by mistake
giving additional access more than that
is required. So super important. And
then you need other integrations like
how this conversational uh chatbot will
be you know presented whether it's a
slack integration it can be anything
maybe a custom application so on and so
forth and the data can reside in
different data sources. So that's
another thing. The third use case talks
about the marketing. If you're building
it for a brand so obviously those
requirements data requirements will be
different. So now that we have
established that our data requirements
will be different for different use
cases. So now let's take a deeper dive
and double click on the travel agent.
Let's say I have a travel agent. What do
I need? First we have all know about the
prompting. I'm not going to repeat that
in this session. So you need a prompt.
You need a system prompt plus your user
queries and your user queries will
become part of your prompt. Right? So
the query will be passed into that's
again your data the instructions is your
data and uh sometimes you can have like
a prompt uh catalog or a template based
on different requirements. Your agent
might choose to pick up a specific
prompt you know who knows the way you
design or the way uh your business
requirements are will derive how the
design will look like. Then the second
third is context. Now this context is no
longer static. It's coming from your
data again right and the data can be
different data services data sources and
then the model that you are using maybe
you're using out of the box model but
maybe you have fine-tuned the model
again you need data for training your
model representing your company so you
need data in every step before you can
get meaningful output now one thing that
is not mentioned over here is the
responsible AI part which I'm not losing
sight of and I'm going to talk about it
but just in a moment. So now we have
established what we need but you will be
like okay we all know what we need we
have talked enough how will we solve
this problem. So that's where we have
Amazon bedrock.
So, Amazon Bedrock not just provides you
with the choice of the models, but it
also provides you with some of the
amazing features such as bedrock data
automation using which you can build
your custom data pipelines uh transform
your data and we'll talk about that. Or
if you want to fine-tune the model, you
have model customizations, you can
evaluate the models, you have model
evaluation. If you want to build a rag
application very quickly, rather than
writing the code from scratch, you can
use u bedrock knowledge bases uh to do
that for you and reduce your time to go
to market and again I'm not forgetting
responsible AI and we have Amazon
bedrock guardrails which can help you
with that. So we have to do whatever we
are doing whether we are building an
agentic rag application or we are
building a let's say summarization
application or a classification
application or detecting a fraud or it's
our same contextual uh chatbot. We all
we have to do all of this in a very
secure and in a private manner with
safety guardrails in place. So that's
what we are going to do. So now bear
with me and let's take another example
of a simple rag application for building
a contextual chatbot. Let's simplify a
bit so that we can go deeper. Right?
So let's say you want to build a chat
application. What would you need? Data.
Now with data we have Amazon Bedrock
data automation using which you can
build your custom data pipelines just
with a single API. Right? That's
amazing. Maybe you have data which is uh
in the form of the videos or text uh or
images. You need to comprehend those
images because they have information.
When I say images, I'm not talking about
describing a portrait over here. I'm
talking about you might have financial
documents which have charts, which have
line graphs and you need to make
business sense out of it. How would you
do that? Right? So, you need some
mechanism to do it. Of course you can do
everything on your own but how we can
make it faster right that's where
bedrock data automation comes into play
then next we have Amazon bedrock
knowledge bases now you would say that
yeah I can build you know a contextual
based chatbot or rag application and
there are so many tools out there but
let's talk about how knowledge bases can
help you one way is what do you really
need when you are building an
application we have talked about data
processing and bedrop knowledge bases
have native support for bedrop data
automation. Then we need to define a
chunking strategy. Do you want to build
a logic for your own chunking strategy
or you want to just leverage some of the
things which are out of the box such as
if you have complex tables and stuff you
can use hierarchical chunking, semantic
chunking but then you would say yeah
that's good money but sometimes we need
the custom logic for chunking. So you
can actually do that and then you can
augment the prompt. You would need to
vectorize it. You can select a
particular foundation uh model uh
embeddings model for um creating the
embeddings and we provide you the choice
of using which vector store to store
your embeddings. Once all that has been
set up, the data ingestion is set up,
the incremental updates to the data is
set up because that's what
knowledgebased brings out of the box.
You don't have to write that custom
logic. Right? Once that is all set up,
what do you need? You need APIs to
retrieve the information. Right? So when
when I say retrieve there is actually a
retrieve API using which you can
retrieve uh the similar content and then
when you are saying I'm doing the search
um yeah semantic search is good but how
do I optimize on search so there is
hybrid search so we provide you those
options and you can pass it as
parameters rather than implementing it
on your own right and now that we have
established on how this retrieve API
works you can augment it with a model
and then uh get the response back. But
there are so many different techniques
like reranking, post-processing, uh
query decomposition. So we have uh
another API which we call retrieve and
generate which can do everything out of
the box as the name suggest and also
provide you with controls such as oh I
want reranking, I want u query
decomposition. So all you have to do is
pass in the par right parameters. If you
have complex queries, it can handle
that. Okay. So now we have the rag
application. We have processed our data.
We have the rag application. But
remember I talked about the guardrails,
right? We need to generate responses
responsibly, right? So that's where
Amazon bedrock guard rails provides you
with so many features and uh with this
limited time I cannot go into each and
every feature but think of it we are
taking example of a contextual based
chatbot right I want the users or the
information that is being presented to
my end user to be to not have the PII
right or maybe not have any um keywords
which are not good because sometimes
models can say stuff that they are not
supposed to right uh in a casual coffee
chat that's okay but not in a formal
setting when you are being recorded
right so that holds the same for our
models as well so that's where Amazon
bedrock guard rails comes into play you
can create like your own policy you can
define your own custom guardrails uh
give examples of what is not to be
shared even ground your responses
reduce hallucinations and then figure
out how your users are interacting when
they are triggered because everything is
logged and you can identify your user
patterns as well with that right so now
we have this chatbot right bear with me
just visualize it uh you have
established uh the data processing using
BDA you have established a rag
application using Amazon bedrop
knowledge bases and you have created
guardrails and you have integrated that
with uh with your knowledge bases just
because there is a native integration.
So you would think that yeah I'm all set
right of course you're all set but how
about the coconuts that we talked about
right they have to come into play
because we mentioned that so we will
talk about coconuts uh but before that
uh I was supposed to actually transition
it when I say your application is ready
so now let's say your application is
ready and then you have images and it's
able to give you the responses and
search uh back in the form of the images
right you have ingested the documents so
everything is ready you're getting the
responses back but yes now let me come
back to the coconuts
so yeah the dance I like I like the
dancing coconuts but let's derive
meaning out of it so far we have been
talking about data processing how data
is important how which bedrock features
can help and now coconuts
yes because that is one thing that I
want you to remember when you get out of
this home because coconuts are super
important and you will see how right.
So actually what happens is lot of uh
people have talked with me about um the
best practices of building rag
applications and these are not just for
the rag applications actually they some
of these concept or most of these
concepts can be extended to other
generative AI applications as well right
so we'll talk about that so I want to
you know have some time for to go into
this because this is important So now
you have this rag application but
remember we started with the data and we
talked about how chunking strategy is so
important right and having the right
strategy will make the difference in the
accuracy of the generated responses.
So this is an important step right but
this is only a step. The second part is
optimization.
I talked about re-ranking. I talked
about parsing, hybrid search. But there
are so many other techniques like query
reformulation, decomposition. You need
to understand how to optimize my
application. But tell me one thing. Can
you optimize without knowing what is
wrong with your with your application?
Can you do that? Any raise of hands? No.
Right? I can see people nodding heads.
So I'll take no. So we cannot because we
need to evaluate our application. So we
will come to evaluation because before
evaluation is we have to see what's
going on and also when we are talking
about optimization one is the optimizing
the accuracy the second is optimizing
the cost right and also the latency how
do we do that because these are the
three pillars of any generative
application performance latency cost
right so how do we do that one way of
doing that is caching your results. So
you can use semantic cache which is
caching. Why? Why semantic? Because in
the generative AI world, we don't have
always the exact deterministic questions
neither the deterministic deterministic
responses up to a certain extent but not
in the exact wordings.
So if we have to do it what we are
looking in our cash is not the exact
question but if similar questions have
been asked I don't need to go and invoke
my foundation model that will charge me
money right and that's number one second
that will also
because it will take time for the model
to synthesize it will add latency right
so we need to take care of both those
things that's why semantic caching
similar questions quickly retrieve if
this has been asked by four.
So now we have got three things. The
second is observability. We need to see
what's going on, right? That's where you
need to log everything user queries,
retrieval hits, model responses because
that's your only way how you can monitor
your um application to improve it to you
know refine it. So that's what we are
doing with observability. So earlier
when my um you know customers used to
ask me about um observability or best
practices I would say you know
observability is the critical component
but now I say please don't go into
production or even do a pilot without
observability. How will you
troubleshoot? How will you improve? How
will you figure out what's going on in
the application if somebody complains?
Right? So you need observability.
But now when we are talking about
observability, now we know we have this
additional data.
What are we going to do with it? We have
to do something with it. We need to
evaluate it, right? We need to figure
out based on my application. Like for
rag application, we have context
relevance because if my context is not
relevant, my search results are not
good. doesn't make sense for me to put
them in front of the model and pay uh
the money and you know because
everything has a cost associated with
that just to get a bad response. Why
would I do that? I would first evaluate
my search results. If my search results
are good then only I'm going to augment
my prompt and give it to the model.
Right? So those are the common things
that we sometimes because we are you
know we are quickly doing everything we
forget about it. So we have to rethink
and evaluate our thinking as well as our
application.
So that's super important. But if you
have a summarization use case, you can
have metrics related to summarization.
Right? So that's why I was saying like
these coconut is actually coconuts are
good. They're good for other
applications as well. And then never go
blind. U so we have talked about that.
But what are we going to do? Let's say
in our evaluation something happened, we
figured it out. We need to update
We need to update what? Sometimes our
data because if our data is stale, our
answers are stale. Sometimes we have to
update our strategy. So again coming
back to optimization, right? And once
you have done the updates, please don't
uh feel that you are done and you have
updated. It's all good. You need to test
again. So one is you are evaluating your
application you have updated it but then
you also need to have a test suite
because whenever you are doing this
update these evaluations have to be
automatic and if you have a defined path
on how you are creating this test suite
the chances of you going wrong in your
production application reduces and the
chances that you have a high quality
application out there in production
increases by manifold. So test and once
you have tested and tested and tested
your application, you're ready to crack
your coconut and that's how you will
scale. So not just the coconut, we need
coconuts. And once you have cracked your
coconuts, you can decorate it and you
can have your application into
production and bear the fruits of
success.
[Music]